et pour terminer retour en france où
emmanuel macron reçoit aujourd'hui près
de 300 arqués à l'elysée une rencontre
pour apaiser les mémoires selon la
présidence ces anciens combattants
étaient recrutés par l'armée française
pendant la guerre d'algérie en 2016 déjà
françois hollande avait reconnu les
responsabilités des gouvernements
français dans l'abandon des harkis cette
réception à l'elysée intervient cinq
jours avant l'hommage national aux
harkis instauré depuis 2001 les
précisions de notre reporter et stéphane
se sont allés porter de cette mémoire à
si particulière qui sont accueillis ce
lundi par emmanuel macron 300 personnes
issus par exemple d'associations mais
aussi être des anciens combattants à 10
heures des représentants art qui devrait
prendre la parole s'en suivra à 10h30 un
discours des manuels un maquereau à
l'issue de ces allocutions trois
personnes devraient être a décoré par le
chef de l'état un représentant harkis
blessés au combat un officier français
qui a organisé le rapatriement de
centaines de harkis ainsi qu'une fille
de harki militante de l'égalité des
chances et de la diversité pour rappel
les harkis sont d'anciens combattants
recrutés comme auxiliaires de l'armée
française pendant la guerre d'algérie et
qui ont été par la suite abandonné à
part la france franchir un nouveau pas
dans la reconnaissance du manquement qui
a été fait aux harkis c'est la volonté
du chef de l'état redit verse procédure
d'indemnisation ont déjà arrêté à créer
et en 2016 françois hollande avait
reconnu la responsabilité de la france
dans l'abandon des harkis mais emmanuel
macron souhaite aller au delà le
chantier de la réparation ne se limite
pas à la dimension pécuniaire précise
une source à l'elysée elle est aussi
liée à la reconnaissance à l'ampleur et
à la portée de cette reconnaissance ce
sera donc peut-être un parent vers ce
que réclament depuis plusieurs années
les associations de harkis à savoir je
cite une loi de reconnaissance de
l'abandon des harkis et leur relégation
dans des camps de transit dans des
conditions déplorables